Luke harding is a British author and
foreign correspondent for the Guardian,
who's reported from Delhi,
Berlin,
and Moscow,
and covered wars in Afghanistan
rack
and Libya.
His books include Mafia state in which
he discusses his experience in Russia
and the political system and the
Vladimir Putin as well as the snowden
files.
Very expensive poison.
And His latest a New York Times number
one bestseller,
collusion secret meetings,
the Imani and how Russia helped Donald
Trump when at a book that has captured
the imagination of the United States of
America is doing phenomenally well.
Right.
Tell me why this book is so successful,
please.
Okay.
I think because it tells the Russian
half of the story.
Basically we have a,
a conspiracy,
you can call it an alleged conspiracy
involving a group of Americans,
many working for,
for,
for trump's campaign and indeed
allegedly trump himself and,
and a group of Russians.
And,
um,
quite a lot is known about the Americans
and the story about Donald Trump,
his son,
Donald Trump,
jr jared Kushner,
the president's son of Noah and so on.
But,
but less is known about the oligarchs,
the intelligence officers.
Uh,
and also the fact that the,
the what happened last year,
um,
owes a big debt to,
to the Cold War.
And I would say to the methods of the
KGB,
well,
this,
um,
obviously intrigued because while you
were explaining that it's becomes clear
that what we're talking about is the,
is how power operates covertly and the
kind of alliances that are formed in
order to achieve power sometimes and con
as in this case unconventional or at
least novel relationship.
So to explain to me,
uh,
please look,
what are the key relationships that
determining trump's ascent?
Well,
the story goes back a long way,
but I think to explain it in a way you
need to kind of explain how,
how,
how Vladimir Putin thinks.
And I'm not a,
I'm not a psychologist,
but I spent four years in Moscow working
as a correspondent between 2007 or 2011.
And I kind of got to know their kind of
rather dark techniques,
if you like.
And um,
the thing about Vladimir Putin is he's,
he's a kind of classic KGB spy.
Um,
he,
he spent his career in the KGB,
some of it in communist East Germany.
And he's going to worldview is,
is predicated on the idea that America
is the enemy,
which quite often during the cold war,
it was,
um,
that Russia is encircled by hostile
forces,
um,
and wanting the kgb used to do a lot of,
is to try and influence politics in the
West European politics and American
politics in particular,
and,
and to device kind of strategies.
And,
and the,
the funny thing is that generally these
operations back in the 1980s were not
terribly,
but the age of facebook and twitter plus
the fact that there are all of these
divisions in America Anyway,
um,
I think really open up all sorts of
possibilities,
especially with Donald Trump who,
who for Vladimir Putin was the perfect
candidate.
So what we ha ha what you're saying is
that because of [inaudible] experience
as a politician and as a sort of a
covert agent,
you have a type of politics that we w is
what more covert then it would usually
be.
What is it that is,
why is it significant that uh,
like a president comes to power via
relationships with a,
a previous Lee,
a state that it was previously an
opposition to rather than say through
alliances with transnational
corporations that have explicit interest
in the country where the president is a
diego?
Well,
I'm going to,
I think transnational corporations don't
hack stuff.
Uh,
now a lot of people are kind of the
Americans hack stuff,
that British hack stuff,
the Russians hack stuff.
I think what was different about the
election last year was that,
that um,
it,
if you believe Washington that
essentially kind of crammed in hackers
or quite often these guys are sort of
freelances cooptive by the state,
um,
broken to Democratic Party servers into
Hillary Clinton's campaign.
And by the way,
and to kind of Donald Trump's campaign
as well.
And they just released one set of emails
at moments of kind of maximum
embarrassment for,
for Hillary.
Um,
in the summer of last year.
Just Push,
you had a kind of convention and again
in October and what,
we can't say that that trump one thanks
to booton but what we can say was that
Putin was kind of pushing,
trying to push them across the line and
the v these kinds of kind of hacks
helped that.
Now you might say,
well you know everyone hacks,
that's true,
but this,
this was a kind of an attempt if you
like,
to kind of influence the domestic
political process from far away.
So I think it was kind of different.
And I also think it was
spectacularly successful.
And I suppose it's surprising because
America is usually a country where it is
generally they like to be the people
that's doing the influencing of other
peoples national politics as opposed to
being the recipient or the victim of.
So I suppose what within it is the idea
that power on a geopolitical level is
shifting.
Is that something that's interesting
about it?
Well,
I,
I think it's,
I think it's not so much that kind of
power is shifting because Russia,
let's face it,
it's not an especially powerful country.
It's still a nuclear armed state.
Uh,
and it has got plenty of tanks,
but,
but economically it's,
it's not,
not a pass and it hasn't really,
in terms of ideas,
it hasn't really kind of developed any
great ideas.
I think what it is is it's actually a
story about opportunism that if you are
a kind of unscrupulous,
sort of sovereign power,
um,
that you can do a lot of stuff quite
cheaply.
I mean,
the,
the hacking for example,
was done with phishing emails that,
that people clicked on in the middle of
the night when they were half asleep.
Um,
and some of the other stuff kind of
relatively low budget,
but it's about this sort of classic kgb
doctrine.
It's about exploiting,
um,
the,
the kind of weakness in western society
and turning it to your own advantage.
Um,
I mean I'm not saying preaching can have
created all the problems in America that
they preexisted him,
but he certainly kind of took advantage
of it.
I see.
And I suppose perspective I have is that
there's trump obviously anybody who's
interested in politics and current
affairs,
he's sort of this wonderfully new,
grotesque,
grotesque Avatar upon which we can sort
of hang our intrigue and our
fascination.
But for like,
and then I'm really interested because
of the depth of your experiences of
journalists,
the time you've spent in Russia or
knowledge of the Edward Snowden case.
What is it that in particular about
trump is a distressing it cause like for
me,
it's personally without their breadth
and depth of knowledge that you have,
it seems that he's merely an
amplification of preexisting phenomena.
Just more visible version of what's been
sort of happening anyway.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean I think that's true,
but,
but he's also someone,
um,
who the the savior state and it's rushed
and successor was very keen to
cultivate.
I mean,
this is a matter of facts and history
and,
and the thing is that we're supposed to
keep on talking about the Cold War,
but Donald Trump does something fairly
unused.
In the 1970s,
he married a woman from communist
Czechoslovakia and we know from the
classical art do classified archive
material that sort of checks spies,
catch a very close eye on the couple in
Manhattan.
And,
um,
uh,
talk to Ivanna's father who still live
behind the iron curtain.
And,
and whatever they had on the trumps
would have been fed to,
to Moscow is part of a kind of a routine
thing.
Um,
and you then fast forward to 1987 and
the,
the citizen Soviet government invites
Donald Trump to,
to visit Moscow and an all expenses paid
trip.
And that was one of the things I kind of
discovered was that the Soviet
ambassador literally got off a plane
from Moscow to New York when with his
daughter to trump tower,
saw Mr.
Trump and said,
ms,
Mr.
Trump,
you have the most beautiful building in
America,
you know,
and sort of schmoozed him.
He did the kind of schmoozy thing.
Would it be susceptible to schmooze?
You say the daughter said it was like
honey to a bee,
basically that trump kind of melted
that,
that he liked this kind of flattery and
recognition.
There was a series of lunches and then
an official invite the Soviet
government,
you know,
we'll bring you to Moscow,
et cetera.
Now what sort of significant about that?
I mean two things.
First of all,
the people who are arranged as travel,
where intourist now interests was a
Soviet travel agency.
It was basically the KGB.
I spoken to kind of defectors who,
who've say,
you know,
that the travel agency was the kgb so
that we can say without being
hyperbolic,
the KGB brought Donald Trump to Moscow
in 1987.
Um,
and then he was staying just off Red
Square,
not far away from,
from dead Lenin and from,
from sort of famous sort of pantheons of
Soviet heroes.
And they're,
his room would've been bugged.
Allegedly he was,
he was discussing hotel building.
But in reality this was a classic,
it's cool to kind of cultivation
exercise.
It doesn't mean that,
that,
that he was recruited and was kind of
striding round,
red square wearing a colonel's uniform.
But it means that they were interested
in him.
Um,
and we also know from kind of leaked
papers from that period why they were
interested in him.
They were basically the head of the KGB
was berating,
uh,
his,
his office is all around the world
saying,
you know,
we need to do more to recruit Americans.
And they circulated a personality
questionnaire for the kind of people
they were interested in.
They wanted people who were vein,
uh,
ambitious,
narcissistic,
um,
you know,
adulterous,
perhaps had affairs that could be
exploited.
We're poor analysts and so on.
And you kind of work your way down the
list.
And Mr.
Trump,
God bless him,
ticks every single box.
So the thing is there's a,
there's a big backstory.
I've kind of courtship now that doesn't
mean that,
I mean,
we don't know to what degree trump kind
of cooperative enormous.
But what,
what is very curious is after this kind
of trip,
about six weeks later when he's back in
the u s he takes out a series of front
page adverts in three newspapers
criticizing Ronald Reagan's foreign
policy and he announces,
wait for this,
he's thinking about running for
president.
It doesn't happen.
Soviet Union collapses and his blood
ambitions take another kind of three
decades to flourish.
But what you have to understand is that
these techniques,
meanwhile,
patients,
niece Jeremy trying to do the same
thing,
he's trying to recruit students from
national America.
The,
the,
these techniques are old techniques
updated for,
for 2016,
2017.
When you say these techniques,
the do you mean the relationship between
Russia and trump and trump's,
uh,
sort of aggressive antiestablishment
announcement.
I mean,
the kind of wooing of people who might
be useful.
And it's a bit like,
it's not that the Soviet intelligence
knew 30 years ago he'd be president of
United States,
of course not.
But they saw he had possibilities that
he might be interesting and he with a
range of targets.
But what's interesting is that trump
keeps coming back to Moscow does again
in the 90s and then most famously he
does it in 2013 when he hosted the Miss
Universe beauty contest.
And he's hanging out with oligarchs with
mafia guys where people from the
presidential administration,
all of whom are slapping him on the back
and,
and really,
um,
if you believe the,
the famous dossier by Christopher Steel,
the sort of British spy who set this
whole thing off,
the kind of the cultivation operation
resumed big time about five years ago
and culminated with the Russians helping
him.
Um,
I'm not saying they made him win because
millions of people voted for him,
but helping them,
helping them across the finishing line
in last year's presidential election.
Yeah,
because it does seem like obviously the
fruition of a 30 year relationship,
it seems sort of on off,
I mean there's not continuous but on and
off because prior to the election,
the relationship between sort of covert
relationships between Russia and the
figures in American public life wasn't
really a story that we were that
interested in.
Is it,
is it something that you,
what,
what now is because it wasn't happening?
I mean that there hadn't been prayed
successful and um,
with,
with trump,
I mean it was,
I,
I've talked,
I've talked to Americans who are kind of
in the intelligence world are more or
less doffing their hat and saying this
is one of the greatest espionage
operations we ever seen.
I mean,
they,
they admit it was kind of breathtaking
and when I was a writing my book as
well,
it's trying to write,
I kind of thriller because it is a
thriller or that sort of true there,
there were a couple of questions to
answer and one of them is why is Donald
Trump's so nice about Vladimir Putin?
When you say rude about everybody,
I,
I don't know if he's been rude about
you,
but he's been rude about Theresa May
last week.
He's been rude about the Germans.
He's rude about his Republican Party
allies.
He's worried about everybody.
But the only constant thing that the sun
rising in the morning is that,
that he's always nice about Mr Putin.
He says he's very smart.
He says he believes him.
When,
when,
when Putin says,
you know,
I had nothing to do with the hacking.
Donald,
I believe him.
Well,
no one else does that.
Seemingly he believes the KGB Asian,
the x one.
Um,
and this is very strange and I can kind
of predict confidently the trump will
never criticize Putin.
And you have to ask yourself,
why is that?
And the answer,
at least according to the steele dossier
is because the Russians have got a whole
load of compromising material.
It's called Kompromat on trump dating
back to the 1980s technical stuff,
readouts of his conversations,
agents,
reports,
um,
and uh,
and also allegations that the trump
watch to kind of exotic sex show when he
was in Moscow in 2013,
which mail month may not be true.
But nonetheless,
at the end of the day,
patient has enormous leverage over the
president of the United States.
And that's a remarkable thing.
It is remarkable,
uh,
is it seems,
um,
gosh,
compromise.
I can't imagine what
compromising material would be
constituted of given the stuff that
explicitly like says himself,
like under stuff that bounces off him.
You know,
is it,
I suppose what's difficult about what's
challenging or in treat part or part of
the intrigue?
Is it,
like you said,
it's like the reference points are like
the 1980s in the Cold War and John Le
Carre's rent to you,
it seems there's something slightly
nostalgic but then the entire atmosphere
of the type of,
uh,
sort of ethno nationalism and they're
sort of bravado of trump and sort of a
other emergent strands of nationalistic
politics,
they all swear seem to have something
quite retrospective about them.
So it's an extraordinary move mood,
a mood that seems to be a prevailing at
the moment.
I suppose.
What's,
um,
like you have mentioned what's
interesting to me,
it's like millions of people did vote
for Donald Trump.
The,
the idea of Russian intervention prior
to this would've seemed kind of bizarre.
And like,
obviously this is a very well researched
and you're obviously right,
but what I suppose is like interesting
to me is what are the other reasons that
somebody like Donald Trump would become
president?
What kind of culture becomes susceptible
to a figure like Donald Trump?
What does it tell us?
I mean,
do you think that the,
that the involve that your book is
saying that without the involvement of
Russia,
he would not have Donald Trump as
the president of the United States and
that's what we should focus on it?
No,
I'm not,
I'm not quite,
I'm not quite saying that because I
think,
I think it's going to multicultural.
There have,
there are all sorts of reasons and as
you say,
um,
millions of people voted for him and
clearly it's got a lot to do with,
with post 2008 with the financial crash.
You mentioned global corporations,
the fact that there are large numbers of
people who just feel they've been kind
of cheated by the system and saw trump
has some kind of alternative and all of
that is right and all of that.
It's got nothing to do with Russia bat.
It's also true that the hacking of this
democratic party stuff really helped
him.
I mean it was a beautiful kind of
campaign weapon.
It sorts,
it sort of undermined hillary.
And I'm,
the curious thing about this whole story
is that I'm pretty certain,
and also having spoken to lots of people
in Moscow,
uh,
that,
Putin didn't think that trump would win.
He was the kind of,
for the Russians,
he was the kind of candidate of chaos.
He was the guy who was going to
discredit hillary so that when she
became president,
she would be weak.
She would,
she would be on the back foot.
And meanwhile,
leaving Russia free to do what it likes
on the international stage.
Now,
of course,
they kind of blew the doors off and
trump became president.
And,
um,
that was great.
And so far as the,
I launched my book in the New New York,
but this kind of atmosphere of hyper
partisanship in the states is absolutely
kind of raging.
So all of that chaos is good for Putin.
But on the other hand,
the one thing he really wanted was for,
for America under trump to lift
sanctions against Russia,
imposed Auntie in 2014 by Obama
following the war in Ukraine.
And that hasn't happened because there's
scandal is just turned into her
monstrously big thing and is being
investigated by Robert Miller who is,
who is kind of beating a path to trump
story.
He's the special prosecutor looking at
all this stuff.
Um,
my concern is,
is that in this diagnosis of Russian
involvement being integral to the ascent
of trump,
other lessons may be missed,
like you said,
about the partner Zan atmosphere in
America.
I was recently in America and I sort of
sensed a similar thing.
Um,
do you think that this sort of,
um,
kind of willingness to blame,
like getting it all be it like,
you know,
like,
uh,
like I said to you,
it's obvious from the,
the steele report and the work that you
have done that there is truth in what
you're saying,
but,
um,
you know,
like,
do you think that there's a sort of a,
possibly a sort of a kind of a desire
democratic left sort of center,
left leaning liberal thinking people
just to sort of find a reason why,
why Donald Trump is president?
There isn't because of the massive
failure of liberalism to take care of
the people that it was supposed to
represent.
Yeah.
I,
I'm a,
I mean I get that and I think your,
your,
I think you're basically correct,
but,
but it's,
it's a complex world and two things can
be true simultaneously.
Liberalism as you put it,
may have failed.
Hillary Clinton may have been a weak
candidate who fell to inspire.
Um,
Bernie may have been given a tough time
by the Democratic Party.
Uh,
trump,
let's face it,
for all of his,
kind of,
for all of his kind of recklessness that
there is something pretty mesmeric about
listening to him speak.
Even if he only says the same thing four
or five times.
I mean,
he does have,
I kind of rhetorical Pi,
you have aura almost.
You have to recognize all of that.
But that doesn't mean that the Russians
didn't help him.
And that the point is that this is sort
of seriousness that this is sort of
serious because you think about
Watergate,
you had one group of Americans,
this is a relatively low tech.
Bloc.
Watergate was the packing room,
his seventies with burglars and rubber
gloves and lock pigs.
But he had one group of Americans
smearing another group of Americans in
a,
in a totally disreputable way.
And then Richard Nixon covering up
afterwards.
What you've got here is one group of
Americans,
uh,
basically invoking that,
a sort of traditional adversary of the
United States and getting them to help
chop the legs off an opponent.
Now,
now that is different territory.
I mean I called my book collusion,
but we're sort of,
we're not there yet,
but we're kind of heading into the kind
of treason zone.
It's a lot more serious than a kind of
domestic political squabble.
And I think the worry is,
despite the failure of liberalism as you
put it,
is,
is that what it tells us is that our
democracies are more fragile.
Uh,
two external manipulation of all kinds.
Then we might've thought yes,
but also
like in a way that's quite evident and
obvious in terms of the experience of
ordinary people in a sort of post
globalized world.
They like,
you know,
cause there's sort of that the,
like the analytical strand that would
demonstrate that would suggest that the
reason that trump became popular is
because he's,
it's an emotional experience that people
are voting for trump voters are having.
Like this guy seems to understand how I
feel.
Like what,
while that doesn't make rational sense,
I don't think we're dealing with the
rationale.
Yeah.
But I mean that's,
that's the kind of crucial point.
And that in a way is why it's so
alarming is that,
is that that trump has a kind of master
of this emotionalism.
I mean,
I've got people kind of one storing my
review who bought an egg whisk on Amazon
and then put one star,
oh my book.
Even though they haven't read it or
bought it because they just don't like
the idea in it.
And,
and it's,
it's,
it's the idea that it's not,
it's no more important than what's true.
What's kind of empirically real,
what's important is what people can be
made to believe.
And there's a,
and the thing is,
is a great sort of relativist strand in,
in Russian thinking in Soviet thinking.
I mean,
it was Vladimir Lenin,
the guy behind the Bolshevik revolution
a century ago who basically said that
that truth was subordinate to the class
struggle.
There was a kind of higher truth which
out truth,
the real truth of what what's actually
kind of going on.
And in a way what patient has done is
sort of cynically take that idea and
reproduce it.
So he doesn't need to persuade everybody
that Donald Trump is,
is,
is a great guy and that he's a faithful
husband and all the rest of it.
But he just needs to kind of persuade a
certain number of people that that's the
case.
And that truth,
that becomes a kind of matter.
Truth,
it feels still with me.
Um,
and I think it's quite scary because
ultimately it's a kind of,
where we are now is it's almost like an
assault on,
on rationality and the idea of a,
of a,
of a uni truth,
if that makes sense.
But where does politics have to go?
But that place,
you know,
see like the,
in a way they're sort of trees,
like,
you know,
like whether or not it's treason.
Literally his treats him for another
state to intervene in the democratic
process,
uh,
of,
second nation.
Yes,
of course it is.
But like powerful entities continually
intervene in the democratic process.
So in a way we were already dealing with
that phenomena is just here.
It's a quite,
seems quite defiant and bold it oh,
bloody hell.
And it's literally the Russians as well
as this sort of hyper aggressive,
I mean,
I think it's funny,
isn't it over the last year that the
Democrats had been in disarray,
and let's face it,
British politics hasn't been in great
shape.
And the funny thing is it's been sort
of,
I dunno,
it's been people in civic society,
it's been activists.
It's,
it's been,
it's been infested with Janice like
myself who've almost be kind of filling,
filling the gap.
And I sort of make,
make kind of two quick please.
One is,
I think we need,
I think in our trouble,
confusing times.
We need good method.
We need to be evidential.
We need to kind of admit when we're
wrong,
the facts might change.
And we need to kind of be humble in the
face of some very kind of complicated
stuff.
Uh,
and the other thing I would say is so an
urge people to kind of buy newspapers if
you don't have the Guardian by something
else or just contribute to news because
we need,
we need people doing this stuff,
I think more than ever.
But it feels to me that these categories
are being challenged.
The idea,
even of a nation state,
I think people are starting to feel this
doesn't work for me any more.
They're the,
the,
the United States of America doesn't
represent my interests.
It's kind of a veil that's placed
between me and power.
And now like,
so for me,
that the trump becomes a sort of gross,
a grotesque example of what's proceeded
in Tfa.
Like this is something I've been
mentioned in ever since I heard it in,
in this room.
As a matter of fact,
the academic Kai Hindi,
Andrew's this sociologist said,
Donald Trump is a better president for
African Americans and Barack Obama
because under Donald Trump we are
confronted with the truth of what
politics
actually is,
what race in America actually is,
rather than dealing with the temporal
distraction.
That was,
that was Barack Obama and out like,
you know,
I'm in no position either racially or
academically to make such an assertion,
but something about that resonated very
deeply with me and it seems like that
while we sort of get all anxious about
this,
of which agencies are involved in
organizing news empower,
the key issue is,
are ordinary people being given access
to power?
Are they able to control their lives?
No.
Were they able to prior to Donald Trump?
Is Donald Trump sort of worse than a bit
nasty seeming,
madly sexist and in some instances
vulgar and grotesque,
almost beyond imagination quite clearly.
But what concerns me is this sort of
attempt to sort of scramble backwards to
look,
just can we get back to where we were
eight years ago when it was at least
nice seeming people that were doing
stuff less vividly.
But that,
but that's not my thesis.
Um,
brilliant thesis on the involvement of
Russia.
But like I said,
but what concerns me is that how this
will be used by neo liberal politicians
in the United States of America to sort
of try and reinstate what proceeded
trump when the lesson that really needs
to be learned.
It's politics needs to radically shift
the way that power is organized,
needs to radically shift.
And like,
it's not like,
you know,
this just Asher,
Tony Blair back in or Bill Clinton.
That's not the answer.
Um,
I think I did this disagree with you,
but,
but I,
I sort of think,
um,
one thing we need is we need good
storytelling actually.
Um,
we were talking about shifting power
back to the people.
We need to tell good stories.
We need to engage people in,
in this stuff because obviously it
fascinates you and it fascinates me.
But it leaves some people kind of cold.
And I,
I'm not sure that,
that,
you know,
the stories,
the little mini stories that Donald
Trump tells on twitter,
very powerful.
They're very emotive that get food to
millions of people.
But,
but um,
there are other stories as well.
And I think at the end of the day,
my job is to try and,
um,
in the areas I understand,
you know,
Russia and also did lots of stuff on
offshore,
on,
I did the Panama papers,
the paradise papers is to,
yeah,
I did Snowden,
I did the Wiki leaks stuff.
I've done all of these kinds of,
the big investigations last for years
and I've sort of written books about
most of them is to actually take these
kind of quite complex themes and to tell
them in a,
in a really exciting and racy way,
it's nonfiction.
It's all true.
It's all,
it's all,
it's all granted,
but so people can kind of read them,
not necessarily scholars or students
from international relations,
but the kind of thing you can read on
the beach or on a train.
Oh two things that I want to do,
like in this,
this next beat of the interview.
One is I want you to,
if you don't mind,
read us what you think is the bit that
exemplifies what you've just said.
Then like sort of populist,
accessible,
thriller,
right in from this book,
collusion.
And now I think he's,
can you explain this story of Edward
Snowden is like [inaudible] sort of,
he,
he roic
pail of our time and I,
I'd like to,
you know,
like sort of give,
this is precedes Donald Trump.
You know,
like this is like,
you know,
this sort of like exposure of corruption
and the way that it was handled.
The White Bengal,
donald snowed a that,
that,
sorry,
the Edward Snowden was exiled.
You know,
this all happens for trump's not on the
landscape at this point.
This is all under Obama and this isn't
the proceed previous administration.
Can you explain it?
Tell us like,
you know,
using your thriller and pop from the Ra
skills.
A little more about that.
No,
no,
you're teasing how routine,
sorry.
So what do you want me to do?
Sorry Dude.
It's no to one first cause cause he
seems to me like a hero.
I can get my chops around.
Well,
I mean think about snowden is that he's
a kind of classic whistle blower and,
and um,
uh,
I mean I read a book about her man that
I'm kind of very admiring of him.
Uh,
essentially what he was someone from
inside the American intelligence
community who realized,
uh,
to his kind of gradual horror that the
United States government and the UK by
the way,
and various kind of Anglo Saxon partners
where hoovering up all of our electronic
stuff,
regardless of whether we were criminals
or old ladies or students doing gcse.
It was all being sucked up.
Text messages,
web searches,
emails and,
and then,
and then that kind of geolocation data
you have from your iphone,
so where you've been,
et Cetera,
all of that is recorded every two
seconds.
And there'd be no public debate or
conversation or kind of reckoning as to
whether it was appropriate.
And the volumes had gone from small in
about 2002 massive billions,
billions a day,
30 billion plus items a day.
Uh,
and he,
he blew the whistle.
He leaked the stuff to my newspaper,
The Guardian.
He fled to Hong Kong and he's now living
in exile in Moscow.
He kind of got stuck there basically by
mistake and I think he's a kind of
heroic figure who kind of pulled across
the curtain and showed us the real
nature of,
of of reality in the 21st century and at
least allowed us to have a kind of
proper conversation with power about
what's appropriate and not appropriate.
Okay.
Wow.
That was brilliant.
So like,
you know,
if that's what's proceeding and trump,
how significant is the Fisher that he
represents in,
cause it's not like he what proceeded
had any values anyway.
These are these they are captured.
So like I can really understand how that
the,
there is an appetite for trump for a
figure that's like,
you know,
these,
trust these people you it or drain the
swamp.
I can see how that kind of language is
going to be resonant when it's in the
ether.
Anyway.
That was what proceeded him.
Was that an environment that required
Edward Snowden and when it would snow
and does do that,
it's not like this guy's a hero.
Bring it back.
Let's have a parade.
Drape him in the Stars and Stripes.
No,
the guy goes and lives where Russia now
the feelings in this one?
I,
I mean it's quite,
it's quite interesting because obviously
I wrote a book that the American
intelligence community didn't much like,
I think there might like this one a bit,
a bit more because I won essentially
because,
um,
the,
there are questions inside Washington.
I mean basically what I was told,
having taught a sources here,
here,
and,
and in the states a lot is that,
you know,
there are a lot of Americans,
it's inside this intelligence
establishment,
let's call it that.
If you like,
who,
um,
disagree with what the presence doing.
I mean,
generally they tend to be kind of more
right leaning than left.
But Obama,
they might not like what he was doing,
but,
but essentially they recognize his right
to do it.
And the thing about trump,
what makes him different is that they
are genuinely asking whether he's a
Patriot actually,
whether he puts American values or
however you want to call it first
American democracy faster,
whether actually he puts his own
personal and family interests above
everything and what deals,
especially financial deals.
He might have cut with Moscow both
recently and in the past.
And so that we're in a very curious
place.
We,
we're in a sort of situation where we
don't entirely know where the real
loyalties of Donald Trump are,
but what are these values?
What are the values that he's breaching
like now,
because I have what I sense the energy
that I sense that he is writing.
Is it kind of an emergent rage coming
from the feeling of nihilism coming from
hold on a minute,
this then this isn't real.
None of it's true.
So like,
you know,
like so when people are kind of like,
oh,
this guy's an anomaly or now an outrage,
I feel like,
well what,
what are these values?
I mean,
of course it's disgusting.
Some of the things he said about women,
some of the racist stuff,
all disgusting.
But when it comes to like,
what is this citadel that's being
defended?
Because it seemed like it was pretty
disgusting.
Anyway.
And now I'm asking you this as a person
that knows a lot about international
politics,
like the show,
but I mean,
I,
you know,
I'm,
I'm not a politician.
I kind of described ran it,
but I don't know.
I mean,
I guess what I would say,
if we can just sort of take a America
out of it.
So it's not just kind of your eras
facing until,
could it more generally?
I mean,
I,
I sort of,
I've spent a lot of time in my kind of
career as a reporter for the Guardian as
a foreign correspondent in war zones.
I mean,
I've,
I've been in pretty sketchy places in
Afghanistan and Libya and Iraq and,
and Ashley,
what do you talk to ordinary people?
They don't,
I mean,
I wouldn't say that kind of neolistic
that there,
but they did kind of want,
they want sort of decency.
They want kind of healthcare.
They want jobs,
they want their kids to have a future.
They want sort of,
uh,
they want governments that change.
I mean that,
that's the kind of key thing about
governments is that one,
one law,
it has to go in a lot has to come in and
maybe I'm set fantastically old
fashioned fuel for your program.
But I actually do believe in,
in kind of brilliant basic human rights
and universal values were supply
everywhere,
whether it's America,
Russia,
central London or ever.
And I think we've slightly lost track of
that.
I,
and I actually think,
I see that these places you were a
foreigner or Afghanistan,
Iraq,
Libya,
all countries chewed up by this thing
that we're trying to preserve and
cherish.
And there,
no,
I mean we're not trying to cheer up
interventionism I mean,
we're not trying to kind of defend kind
of these kind of grandiose misconceived
imperialistic projects.
I,
I'm,
I'm starting from a position of,
you know,
if you,
if you're a war reporter,
actually it's a very easy thing to do.
It's much more easy to report on war
than is to report on Brexit because you
just talk to ordinary people.
You ask them stories,
you'd ask them about their lives,
their kids,
why they fled.
You know,
what they saw,
who they met,
he pointed a gun at them and he tell
those stories as well.
My point about storytelling,
I just think it's really important,
it's kind of elemental that we tell the
right stories that we tell kind of pro
human stories,
but that,
that we,
we try and seek the truth rather than a
truth and also that we don't totally
lose faith in,
in humanity and kind of succumb to the
Neil Ism that you were talking about
earlier on and we must never do that.
We must never do that.
When you're in your work as a war
correspondent,
it becomes clearly human cause it's an
identifiable situation and you feel you
can obviously connect with that humanity
until their stories where it was in more
complex situations.
Somehow it is what it is.
Opaque.
Well it can be.
It can be very,
he said,
she said that's the,
that's the bump.
It can be,
you know,
there's kind of,
there's sort of the,
you kind of have to sort of go and find
banners and sometimes when you're doing
that,
you actually lose sight of the truth,
which is,
for example,
one group of people are shelling of
bunch of civilians.
There's not really he sheds.
She said it's just,
he shall,
Ye shall know that just,
you know,
that is the reality.
You have little pun there about people
being killed by heavy artillery.
And we'll read us the best bit or not
the best bit a bit of this like,
you know,
pop you laray and all of that.
Yeah.
Um,
well,
so this book begins with Christopher
Steele,
who's the British spy at the heart of
all this.
Uh,
and I went to see him about four weeks
before his famous dossier was published
in January by buzzfeed.
Um,
and I go into his office,
a modest ground floor suite knew this
was the best bit straight away.
Cause this is a bit,
you do when you do readings.
Is it,
this is the first time anyone's asked me
to read from this book.
So I'm actually,
I'm actually improvising king.
No,
no,
it's a bit old school reading.
But anyway,
um,
so yeah,
grandpa sweet couple of bear rooms
painted.
I rewire to kind of map of the wwe world
fixed to one wall.
This is Christopher Steele's office
lined up near the director's desk.
He's the director of this business
intelligence,
um,
uh,
from a nesting Russ Russian dolls called
Matryoshka,
a souvenir from Moscow.
They feature Russia's great 19th century
writers,
Tolstoy,
Gogol,
Lermontov,
Pushkin.
Um,
and I say,
and the tumultuous days of 2016,
the dolls were as good as a ma,
as good as any metaphor for the
astonishing secret investigation had
recently been asked to do.
It was an explosive assignment to
uncover the Kremlin's inner most secrets
with relation to one Donald J.
Trump to undress them one by one.
Like so many dolls until the truth was
finally revealed and it had Russian
belts in it.
I'm absent some figures from Russian
literature.
I thinking I've wanted to know what was
going to happen next.
Read the book,
take it to ridiculous extremes.
Entry could be going on me,
snatch me out of my life.
Bury me in language.
No,
no,
no.
I will read your book.
I'll read it when bloody hell might come
on.
You've got this number one best seller.
What'd you want?
You want everyone in the world to read?
He can't give into that kind of ego.
That's one of the things.
Your story or your lecturing me on ego.
What,
who,
who is better qualified?
Come on this.
Getting some more stuff.
There's going to alike like a proper
deep gear in here.
I mean one thing,
one thing I didn't talk about my
experiences in Moscow,
I didn't know if you want to hear about
that.
They kind of um,
helps shape the book and write the book
because basically after doing all of
this war that we talked about earlier,
um,
in the Middle East and elsewhere,
I lived in Germany for awhile.
I did side trips to Baghdad and then I
was posted with wife,
wife,
and two kids.
Well not,
not in war zones,
but kind of on forum postings.
And then we moved to Moscow.
And this was,
do you remember that?
This is the case of my,
uh,
the celebrities,
my previous book of very expensive
poison.
I don't know if you remember the case of
Alexander live in Yanco was a Russian
desk dissident,
famously,
famously poisoned umbrella.
No,
it wasn't a brother.
It was a radioactive cup of tea,
uh,
given by two criminals,
assassins in a hotel not too far away
from here.
Um,
and I arrived shortly after his murder,
uh,
and I started investigating this story
and it was made pretty clear to me in
Moscow.
The,
my,
my inquiries were most unwelcome and I
had strange guys wearing cheap black
black leather jackets and brown shoes
following,
following me around the icy streets of
the city.
And it's scary,
mate.
Well,
hang on.
I mean that,
that was,
that was the funny bit because that was
more kind of clue.
So then kgb,
I mean that was,
that was,
um,
uh,
that,
that was kind of okay because they will
come and sit next to you in a cafe and
why it was clear that,
not like that you wouldn't lie that
well.
Okay.
So there was that and there was sort of
electronic surveillance as well.
So whenever I made it kind of phone call
or told a joke about Pooja and there
would be a kind of ominous on the phone
with a line cut.
So then you redialed you make another
joke about Putin.
And so it was all very demonstrative.
The idea was to sort of show that,
that they were on your case,
that they were listening.
Um,
and,
and the thing that really,
um,
kind of disturbed us because I was,
cause I said by kids were at that point
our kids were six and nine was we had a
series of breakins at our apartment
where we live in Moscow.
And it was done in a kind of most
obvious way.
This is from the kind of KGB manual to
show that they've been there.
And one of the things they did,
for example,
was when we were living on the sort of
50th floor of an apartment block in
Moscow,
that they busted open the the window
next to my six year old son's Ikea bed
with a sort of 20 meter drop to the
courtyard below.
So that was kind of broken and left
open.
In other words,
implying that he might just meet with a
little accident and there was a lot of
very crude stuff like that family fate
is deleted.
Um,
and,
um,
uh,
we,
we sort of sought advice from the
British embassy in Moscow and they
basically said,
you are bugged.
And I said,
well,
look,
is there,
is there anything you can,
you might do about this?
Can you get rid of the bugs?
And they said,
well,
now we come,
you know,
have a cup of tea and a biscuit.
You just have to live with it.
So we had,
we were basically,
and we discovered there was video as
well.
So we have three and a half years before
I was eventually deported from Russia
under surveillance in the bedroom,
the living room everywhere.
Um,
and,
and the reason it's relevant is that
when you,
when you sort of try and think about
would Putin of tapes,
Donald Trump in Moscow in 2013,
you,
Betty Wood,
this is what they do.
This is what they did to me.
If they have a whole technical
department that does this stuff,
they're quite fixated on sexual
behavior.
Uh,
on one occasion they left a sex manual
bile bed when we'd been away on holiday
and Berlin and we came out to discover
this,
this book in Russian,
uh,
lying there.
And I sort of picked it up and I thought
this is the most strange moment of mine.
I've what message of the KGB 20%.
Well,
you're not a bit frightened mate.
eight went out that window bit.
I mean,
yeah.
I mean the thing is that what they've
very good at is they're sort of try and
find your point of vulnerability.
So for most people is their kids there,
you know,
the idea that something might happen to
your children.
It is,
it's kind of really a sort of primal
thing.
And in my,
I think the goal was basically to make
me stop writing articles that they
didn't like and probably to decide with
my wife that it was time to pack our
bags and leave Moscow.
Well because,
well,
first of all,
because my wife's brother cool and,
and independent and kind of feisty and
she had her own life and she was
enjoying it.
I lucky in Russia you'd have to part
with a sex manuals when it wasn't,
I mean,
it wasn't open windows.
I wasn't quite as crudely phrase,
but,
but yeah,
I mean you're,
you're right.
Um,
but also I was kind of furious.
I mean,
I sort of thought,
well that's what they want me to do.
And so actually it didn't stop my
reporting in fact rather so sharpened
it.
But what it did do was to include it in
the reporting.
I could am I in the book I read off,
I got kicked out,
which was called Mafia state,
which,
which I read from London.
I'd been bender,
been expelled from that point,
but at that point,
but what it did do was give me a kind of
insight into,
into the thuggish newness to sort of
crude nature of the KGB.
I mean,
they're very keen to sort of show that
there are master that they kind of
control the situation.
Um,
they don't subtle.
and they,
they kind of target people messed at
random.
And,
and the,
the contacts I made there that the way I
saw how kind of the Russian intelligence
kind of know matrix works really helped
with this book on,
on Donald Trump.
Not,
not because,
you know,
trump trump what he had slightly
different experiences,
but I kind of,
I understand they're kind of dark
wellview actually.
Um,
and we survived it.
Congratulations.
And it's bloody terrifying now.
So like sort of an aspect of Russian,
the Russian political strife that was
presumably to some degree subordinate,
the KGB,
you're saying it's now been elevated to
supreme potency in the figure of poo in.
So we should expect those tactics.
They're sort of take place it on the
national stage in the way they may have
only done covertly or domestically.
I mean essentially preaching for
[inaudible].
It's Cold War.
He's doing it again this time he's
determined to,
to sort of win.
Um,
he,
he sees Russia and opposition to the
United States.
There's even a Russian word for it,
which KGB,
it's a in all the KGB manuals,
it's called love me proteomic love.
And they put ethnic,
which wins the main adversary gladney
procurement.
That,
that's,
that's really how Putin views views the
u s and we use the UK as a kind of
little sidekick of the glove and the
protein ethnic.
Um,
and um,
he's doing a pretty good job of
prevailing,
I mean,
when a Cold War,
well,
you,
you don't necessarily win,
but what you want to do,
you want to do,
you want to keep,
keep your enemy in a state of perpetual
weakness and,
and disarray.
Uh,
and they're pretty good at that.
That's pretty good.
That you said earlier that the sort of
American secret service community
regarding this is a sort of an
inconceivable master stroke.
What's occurred that there sort of a
spirit of chaos has been unleashed in an
American?
I W Bruton didn't do the unleashing.
I mean the chaos was there.
He,
he,
he just took advantage of it basically.
And,
and,
and it's in a way,
it's kind of quite crew,
but it's quite effective.
I mean,
he had gangs,
they've got this troll factory,
there's famous troll factory and some
Pittsburgh weather up there are gangs,
have sort of cynical students earning
$15,000
a year who posts comments in,
in pretty good English on western
websites praising Putin or,
or,
or adopting kind of talking points.
They did it in the Guardian for years
and years and years.
And during the American election,
these Russian students called Sergei
were pretending to be text and
housewives called Karen,
uh,
writing about,
you know,
tweeting,
um,
gifts of Donald Trump propping a Mexican
in the bin as saying,
Cheerio Pal,
you know,
stirring up passions over immigration,
pretending to be activists from black
lives matter.
Uh,
and loads and loads of Canada.
Yeah.
Loads of other Americans were,
were gleefully re tweeting this stuff,
seeing it on their facebook pages,
liking it thinking I Look Karen,
you know I like,
I agree with Karen and Karen is really
Sergei and say you don't need to be a
genius,
you just need to be a kind of
opportunist and you need a little bit of
luck.
So these,
I suppose that even the sort of slightly
comedic act of like
sp or would you,
would that even work at the title
espionage and sort of subterfuge?
Subterfuge has an impact on the sort of
feeling of being a marrow.
It permits new permits,
a different kind of discourse.
What I was saying that is the war for
the mind.
It's kind of almost sort of,
it's shopping what's already in your
head and it's kind of an,
and actually if you kind of micro
target,
if you look at swing states,
you can have quite an influence.
Now,
what's interesting is that sort of a,
you know,
everyone's on facebook and facebook said
initially know that the,
the,
the Russians,
what Russians,
what are you talking about?
And then something,
he came back to Congress two months ago
saying,
AH,
yeah,
we've,
we've found all of these accounts paid
for in rubles from Moscow were,
yeah,
they were actually pretending to be
activists are pro trump supporters,
but really they were Russian systems.
Do you think then if the,
is that something is sort of broadly
like something has comedic is that can
be effective in the war for mental space
then what we can,
can we speculate as to what the impact
is of that,
the on going,
uh,
what do I want to,
how do I want to turn this,
this sort of maintenance of the dominion
of a sort of a capitalist consumer
culture.
How we're continually,
how our thoughts are marshaled,
controlled,
how we continually stimulated market it
at,
you know,
like,
so what do you think of those as
obviously an excellent and did diligence
story teller.
You're probably one of the best people
doing this.
I'm guessing.
If you look from the justice for Tamir
and your CV,
then it would snow.
Then you've done in paradise papers,
you've done the collusion with Russia.
What do you think?
Um,
what do you think of?
No,
see,
like these,
this is an anomaly,
isn't it?
Like it seems to me that just different
people are getting a little go at
telling the story,
but it really only using this
sort of,
they're using techniques that existed
before,
in a sense.
The there in a way to have aims and ends
that aren't that different from
previous,
I want to say administrations,
but it seems like previous movements,
previous movements in American life.
So over the last 30 years of what's
happened to,
there's probably created this state of
disillusionment and disenfranchisement
where the mind can be sharpened to a
point of nationalism.
So what do you think about like that,
those kind of stories that are sort of
so pervasive that they are harder to
identify it?
Do you think it's,
starts to sound a bit too wacky and
conspiratorial?
You know,
cause I feel like that's what's the
reason why I'm interested in Luke is
this [inaudible] my,
again,
my intuitive sense is that the,
the,
the oft made connection between Brexit
and trump is a reasonable one in that
you have swathes of people feeling a
sense of that they are lacking purchase.
They have had enough.
And my fear and concern is that by
diagnosing the anomaly as the problem,
we prevent people from analysis
analyzing the proceeding conditions but
inevitably led towards it.
And why I'm fascinated by people point
it out like more
covert,
more insidious forms of tyranny such as
what proceeded trump interest me.
Do like,
well,
I'm,
I mean I,
yeah,
I mean I take your point,
uh,
but I,
I do,
I do think that these two things can,
can both go on.
I mean the,
that,
the external conditions put,
we call it color that they're produced.
Brexit absolutely are real and they are
primarily British.
Um,
and,
and we,
we can talk about them forever.
And there are people who are genuinely
disillusioned and have good reason to be
kind of fed up with the system in the
state.
All of that is true,
but at the same time it's perfectly
valid to see whether,
for example,
Sergei and Saint Petersburg was also
setting up an account,
uh,
tweeting in favor of brexit because we
know that that is the case.
There were various kind of trolls
pretending to be Brett's micro topic
targeting leave leaning voters during
the run up to the election.
And the pigeon is very delighted with
brexit because it weakens the European
Union and it weakens the UK.
Uh,
and that that's all to his advantage as
he sees it.
And they're also question marks about
where the money came from behind the
leave campaign.
That,
I mean,
it may all have been legitimate
donations from,
from,
from noble business people,
but,
but there's a lot of,
it has been routed through offshore and
it's kind of terribly a pig.
So I think we can,
we can diagnosed the social ills in our
own country,
but also be alert to the possibility of
external manipulation,
whether it's from Russia or indeed from
anywhere else because he's fascinating.
Yeah,
it is fascinating.
And it,
it is a,
it is a conundrum because if we,
if we lose faith in democracy,
if we lose faith in,
in,
in the possibility of a decent or a
better society,
if we lose faith in each other,
what,
where do we go?
And the thing about Putin is that he is
a kind of supreme near list and he,
he,
he likes those conditions where people
end up believing in nothing because that
suits his sort of agenda because it,
he can do his sovereign thing without
anyone calling him out.
So,
so I think we,
we,
we do need to be even something,
but we do need to be honest,
um,
uh,
about what's going on.
Presumably,
you know,
having lived in Russia,
I exposed as a sense that I'm actually
okay.
Okay.
If there is going to be a geopolitical
struggle,
uh,
on the ultimate scale,
probably would prefer things to be how
they are in Britain than Russia having
lived there.
Those ration Porno mags.
Yeah.
It was that,
it was actually a book on sex and
relationships,
but they had quite leave it.
They deliver.
It was bookmarked help limb outage while
they hit it was bookmark to a page on
orgasms.
So I think they were trying to tell me
I'm a while it was
supposed to be both and I think I didn't
know whether they were making a comment
about frequency or technique or all kind
of inconsistency.
Oh,
I'm not sure.
But basically they were saying,
you know,
we are watching you if they're well
intended,
what if we re reposition Putin is a well
intending sort of avuncular figure there
simply to try to help you if your sex,
life and American,
you know what I think,
I think you should get him on your show
and you can talk to him and then you can
decide.
I can't imagine.
But what I certainly agree with you on
luke is that we cannot afford to become
disenchanted with the potential for
democracy to be effective at.
Because I think that in my own
diagnosis,
which I will happily admit is from
limited resources.
It feels to me that this despair is what
has contributed to these dis junks to
these sort of sort of horrifying moments
if it culturally whatever side of those
divides you stand on.
Even when I,
people of marching in Charlottesville
when it's sort of outburst of rage and
low thing and sort of targeted at
minority is the,
you know,
I,
I feel,
I feel afraid.
Yeah.
From what I sense is that the solution
he is to have an effective democracy and
my worry about something that's such a,
uh,
an evident operation,
aberration operation such as trump such
as brexit,
is that people
won't
look at what proceeded it.
Cause I feel that that's the platform
upon which these things rest
for sure.
And I think you're right,
but I think we have to kind of keep
calm.
I mean,
but without being too kind of platitude
in this week,
we have to kind of love each other,
but we do have to kind of interrogate
reality and,
and try and make sense of it and tell
good stories.
Yes,
I think you're right.
And you're certainly doing that.
Thank you very much for the brilliant
work that you've done as a journalist
and as a writer and bringing stories
that are complex and difficult to
understand to a wider audience that it's
great work that we're doing.
And he's obviously taken a great deal of
bravery,
particularly what you've undertaken in
war conditions and under kind of level
of scrutiny in Russia.
I don't think I'd enjoy that really
freak out.
But just to say
the really brave people in the story are
there not,
not,
not people like me with a foreign
passport that the Russians or other
people in,
in,
in states where human rights are not so
great because they pay a bigger price.
Very often they,
they take take risks.
Some of the people I knew of
journalists,
politicians have since been kind of
murdered.
No,
I'm not.
So,
so I,
I sort of think we should sort of solute
people inside those countries who are
trying to
pastry to kind of change things for the
better because they're tremendously
pray.
Thank you very much.
Yeah,
that's a beautiful thought to end on.
Thank you,
Luke.
Thank you.
I really enjoyed,
it was good chat,
isn't it?
That we had,
it was great surprise that you've not
been asked to read before.
Why is that not happening?
I think that went out about 20th
no much understand.
She's a nostalgic medium.
It's a long form interview.
I love it.
I absolutely love it.
Thank you so much for your time,
man.
Thanks.